The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah,
let's show the answer.
All right.
For a special treat,
special benefit--
I'm not sure what to call
it-- something special later
in the class, does
someone want to tell me
why that's the right answer?
AUDIENCE: Well as
we did last lecture,
we crossed off the k2
because that's the slow step.
So it doesn't matter as much.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah.
And so when you get rid of
that, when the k minus 1
is really fast
compared to k2, k2
is very small compared to that.
So you get rid of it.
And that simplifies
the expression.
So temperature-- today's lecture
is largely about temperature.
But we're going to
tie in all sorts
of other things we've
learned over the course
of the semester.
So I'm very excited.
Some of my very favorite
topics are coming back today.
So effective temperature, we
talked about this a little bit
when we were talking
about making bread,
adding your baking
soda and about rates
and why you put
things in the oven.
And we talked about it has to
do with also the spontaneity,
whether you change
the temperature
and what your delta
H and delta S are.
But we also talked
about rates and that
increasing the temperature
often increases the rate.
So many of us have
observed this.
You increase the temperature,
you increase the rate.
But today we're going
to talk about how
you can quantitatively say
how much the rate might
be changed-- the rate constant
might be changed if you
increase the temperature.
So in 1889, it was a
wonderful day for Arrhenius.
He had been trying to
plot different values
of rate constants
versus temperature
to see what would happen.
And then he tried natural
log of the rate constant k
versus inverse temperature.
And he got a straight line.
And scientists always get
very excited when your data
falls on a straight line.
It means you figured
out some relationship
between two values.
So here is the Arrhenius plot.
And we'll introduce some terms.
So again, we're plotting the
natural log of k versus 1
over temperature, 1 over
inverse kelvin over here.
And here is our plot
of this straight line
that Arrhenius found.
Natural log of k on
the y-axis versus 1/T
gives you a slope then of
minus the activation energy--
so E to the little a is
activation energy-- over R,
our good friend
the gas constant.
And then the
y-intercept over here
is the natural log
of something called
A. We have a lot of different
A's in this particular unit
of kinetics.
This one is factor
A, sometimes called
the Arrhenius factor,
A for Arrhenius.
It has a couple of
different names.
But importantly, it has the same
units as k, our rate constants.
So what this plot told
Arrhenius back in 1889
was that rate constants
vary exponentially
with inverse temperature.
So this was the first
kind of connection
between rate constants
and temperature
that could be used
to kind of come up
with quantitative numbers.
So factor A, this Arrhenius
factor, and the activation
energy, E to the sub a, depend
on the reaction being studied.
So they have to be measured
for the particular reaction.
So it's a clicker competition.
So we'll have a bunch of
clicker questions today.
And why don't you tell me if you
think factor A is temperature
dependent?
All right.
10 more seconds.
Yep.
The answer is no.
And so what is this factor A?
If we think about this in
terms of the plot, what it is
is the rate constant
when 1/T is equal to 0.
Because it is the y-intercept.
And when 1/T is equal to 0,
what has to be true about T?
Yeah.
Infinitely large.
So factor A is the
rate constant at
an infinitely large temperature,
at a huge temperature.
So it's the fastest that
particular reaction could ever
go at this infinitely
huge temperature.
So that's what factor A is.
And of course, we
can't plug things in
and say, how fast is this at
an infinitely huge temperature?
So conveniently, you
can get that value out
of plotting your data.
You measure a bunch of rate
constants versus temperature.
And you plot it
this way, and you
can calculate this sort of
maximum rate constant possible
for this reaction if
you had this infinitely
huge temperature.
What about activation energy?
Do you think that's
temperature dependent?
All right.
10 more seconds.
So no, it isn't.
And so if we sort of just
think about it back here,
the answer is no.
Again, you plot
the rate constants
over all these temperatures to
get one value out of the slope.
So it is largely independent
of any kind of temperature.
You get one activation energy
for the reaction in question.
But it does depend on
the reaction, for sure.
There isn't just one value
for this for everything.
It depends on the materials.
All right.
So let's look at some
other ways that we can
express the Arrhenius equation.
So we have the
Arrhenius equation
written as a straight line.
And we can also do something
very, very simple to it,
which is switch these two terms.
And that gives us what
is officially known
as the Arrhenius equation.
So natural log of k
equals natural log
of A, this Arrhenius
or factor A,
minus the activation
energy over the gas
constant times temperature.
And of course, if you
want to solve for k,
you take the inverse
log of both sides.
And so then k is going to be
equal to this factor A-- again,
measured for every reaction
in question-- e to the minus
Ea, the activation
energy, over RT.
So here is our equations.
These will be on
equation sheets,
so you don't have
to memorize them.
But you already, if you've been
studying your equation sheet
for exam four,
realize that there's
a lot of symbols that are
very similar in these units.
So we have a, in nuclear
chemistry, activity.
So just keep in mind
what equation is what.
When you're talking
about nuclear decay,
you don't have your
activation energy term.
So that should give
you somewhat of a clue.
So one of the
challenges in the final
is making sure you know
which equation is which.
So let's look at an
example now where
if we're given some
of the information,
we can solve for other things.
So an example, this is
classes at lunch time.
So we can think about the
hydrolysis of an average lunch
of sucrose to form a
molecule of glucose
and a molecule of fructose as
part of the digestive process.
So some of you might
have eaten already.
You might be
digesting sucrose-- it
comes in many different
forms-- right now.
So using the information
about activation energy,
we can predict what
the rate constant
is going to be at a
different temperature.
So some kind person measured
the activation energy
for this digestive process
at 108 kilojoules per mole
and also figured out that
the k observed, observed
rate constant, for this reaction
is 1.0 times 10 to the minus 3
per mole or per at
normal body temperature.
And so now we're asked
to calculate what
that rate constant should
be at lower temperature, 35
degrees Celsius, somewhat
below body temperature.
So how are we going to do that?
Well, let's remind ourselves
of our equations, our Arrhenius
equation.
So we know what Ea is.
We were not told what our
Arrhenius factor A is.
We don't know that.
But we do know one
of the rate constants
at one of the temperatures.
So if we combine
these two equations,
then we have an
appropriate number
of variables to
solve for the rate
constant at the new temperature.
So let's combine
those two equations.
So we have natural log
of k2, our rate constant,
at temperature 2
minus the natural log
of the rate constant
at temperature 1,
which can also be expressed
as natural log rate constant 2
over rate constant 1.
And our natural log of the
Arrhenius factor drops out.
And so we have minus Ea,
our activation energy,
over our gas constant times 1
over the temperature minus 1
over the first temperature.
So we can put in our
values that we're given.
So we have our first
rate constant down here,
the rate constant at
the first temperature.
We put in our
temperatures, making
sure we convert them to kelvin
because our gas constant is
in kelvin.
And also, we are going to
convert our activation energy
from kilojoules to
joules because we
want to cancel our units.
So now we can cancel joules.
We can cancel moles.
And we can cancel kelvin.
And so that gives us
a new rate constant,
7.6 times 10 to the minus
4 per mole or per second.
And this is a lower rate
at a lower temperature.
And in fact, that is often true.
You have a lower rate
at a lower temperature.
And this is one of the reasons
why it's a really good idea
to keep your body temperature
at body temperature.
And around this time of
year, people come in to MIT
from warmer climates.
And they do not have
appropriate clothing.
And so your body does not
work well in the cold.
The rates slow down.
You're not digesting things.
Your body is really
not doing anything
at the rate it's
supposed to be doing
these reactions
because they're nicely
tuned to the appropriate
body temperature.
So go out and buy a winter coat.
So this now, this equation
that we just derived
shows us the relationship
between rate constants
and temperature.
So again, natural log k2 over
k1 minus the activation energy
over the gas constant
and our temperature term.
And if we look at
this equation, we'll
realize that if we have a very
large value for this activation
energy, this Ea term
here, that's going
to mean that the
rate constants are
very sensitive to temperature.
If this is small, there
won't be a big difference
between k1 and k2.
But if the activation
energy is really big,
there will be a big
difference between k1 and k2.
The rate constants will be
very sensitive to temperature.
All right.
So now let's think about
rates and temperature.
And let's think of
a cold temperature.
Let's think, for example, of
liquid nitrogen temperatures.
What do you think
happens to an enzyme?
You have enzymes in
your digestive process
that are hydrolyzing
sucrose that you
might have had for lunch.
What do you think
happens to enzymes
if you put them at liquid
nitrogen temperature?
They will slow way down.
One would say they would
stop working entirely.
They would just sort of
be, we call it frozen.
And in fact, I use this all
the time in my research.
So one thing we do, we study
the structures of proteins.
And so we grow these
lovely protein crystals.
And what we can do, we take
these-- a lot of times,
the proteins or enzymes in
the crystals are active.
They're able to convert
reactants to products.
And so we can soak in reactants
and then take our crystals
and dunk them in liquid
nitrogen and then
determine the structure of that.
And if we do it at
different time points,
you can actually kind of
walk through the mechanism
of the enzyme.
Watch what happens at
various different states.
So this is a very common
thing that's used.
We like to do things
at liquid nitrogen
to see things sort of--
we sort of pause it
when it's dumped
in liquid nitrogen.
It stops what it's doing.
And we can capture
its structure.
What do you think about
non-enzymatic reactions?
Do you think they're also
going to be slowed down?
I don't know.
Should we do an
experiment and find out?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Yeah, I think we should.
So we now have-- let's
bring out our demo TAs.
We now have glow sticks.
Glow sticks are in
fact chemicals in there
that when you break them,
you have a chemical reaction.
So we're going to do this.
And we're going to break
them and watch them glow.
Let's break them and
put them in here first.
And then we're going to cool
them down and see what happens
to the chemical reaction.
Here, let's have a
little help over here.
Please break some of these.
AUDIENCE: How do you break them?
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
You break-- see,
you just kind of snap them
and then shake them up.
And I think we'll bring down the
lights so you can all see these
pretty well.
So now the chemical
reaction is going.
And so we can see the
chemical reaction.
That's what's wonderful
about glow sticks.
You can observe the
chemical reaction
because it causes it to glow.
Move so everyone can see.
Now we're going to see what
happens to the chemical
reaction when it slows again.
When the chemical
reaction is slowed down,
you won't see it anymore.
So it'll stop glowing.
That should be good.
We'll do all of
them, and we'll see.
It'll take a little bit of time.
But it should not be too long.
And hopefully, it'll slow down
faster than the liquid nitrogen
destroys the plastic cups.
Yeah, I think you can see
it with the first one now.
Mary, why don't
you come down here?
We have something
else for you to do.
Let's put some liquid
nitrogen in here.
Let's bring up the lights
because our glowing
has stopped.
So another thing
that liquid nitrogen
changes the properties.
So Mary will demonstrate to
you what happens to a flower.
And just like right now,
the flower does this.
But let's put it in liquid
nitrogen and see what happens.
Give it a decent soak.
And now smash it.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you very much,
our lovely assistant.
I will brush off
my computer later.
We have more flowers,
and apparently there's
a broom somewhere.
So if we finish class, for
some lucky other individuals,
you can come down and smash
the rest of the flowers.
So liquid nitrogen really
changes the property of things.
Sometimes it's used
by dermatologists
to remove warts or other things.
They'll dab some
liquid nitrogen on you.
And I always feel like
paying a lot of money
to go have that done-- I have
liquid nitrogen around my lab.
But then I'm like,
yeah, I probably
have enough liquid nitrogen
burns on my figures
already that I don't want.
Crystallographers
who use this a lot,
they'll often be in
a situation where
you have this liquid
nitrogen. And it's
sort of dripping on you.
But you have your crystal,
and if you let go,
then you'll destroy
your crystal experiment.
So you'll have liquid
nitrogen sitting in your palm.
And you're like, OK,
I'm going to get a burn.
Or I'm going to lose my crystal.
And so you decide how
important that is.
And so sometimes
a crystallographer
will walk up to you
and go, see that scar?
That's 1.2 angstrom
data, baby, right there.
So we suffer for our
science sometimes.
So liquid nitrogen is
very-- changes the property.
Cold things are different
than warm things.
Buy a winter coat.
So everything slows
down in the cold,
in terms of
elementary reactions.
Our rate constants slow down.
So now let's think
about a reaction
and what's called a
reaction coordinate
and consider what's
happening in a reaction.
And then we're
going to come back
to thinking about the
effect of temperature,
where temperature really
makes a difference.
We'll quiet down a little.
So considering the reaction
coordinate, reaction coordinate
the reactions of-- you bring
your reactants together
and form your product.
So two things coming together
to form something else,
that is a reaction.
And as you go along
in the reaction,
that's your reaction coordinate.
And we're going
to also introduce
this term of activation
complex or transition state.
So two molecules can collide.
Two molecules
colliding, bimolecular.
But every time those two
molecules come together,
they're not necessarily
going to form a product.
Why?
So only when that
collision energy is greater
than some critical energy--
which is sometimes called Emin,
this sort of minimum energy
to get this reaction to go,
or as I like to call it,
the activation energy, Ea,
that's what we've
been talking about,
our activation energy--
will you get a reaction.
So you need to have
enough energy in your two
things coming together.
Those two things coming together
need to have a critical energy
for them to react.
So why is this true?
You need to have
that critical energy.
But why?
Why is this necessary?
So it's necessary because before
this reaction takes place,
even if it's a very happy
reaction, things need to occur.
So the two things coming
together need to often distort.
Bonds might have to be broken.
And new bonds need to be formed.
And while that is occurring,
while there is distortion
of the bond or
bonds are breaking,
you need to have some
potential energy to do that.
You need some energy to
make that reaction go.
So the potential
energy of the system
increases first while these
distortions are happening.
So the encounter then
between them, you
form some activated
complex, or what's
known as a transition state.
And that activated complex, it
can go on to form a molecule.
Or from that activated
complex, the two molecules
may just go apart again.
So what determines
whether they're
going to go on happily
to form their complex
or going to depart
from each other,
never to form a larger molecule?
And the thing that
determines the fate
is that critical energy.
So only those molecules
with that sufficient energy
to allow for those bond
distortions and rearrangements
will be able to go
on and make this.
And you can think
about this, I think,
in terms of a couple,
a relationship,
that there's always some
work that has to go into it.
It's never perfect.
And if you put in this effort
and this work, you can go on.
And if you don't really have
it in you and you're like, ah,
you walk away.
You don't have that
critical energy.
You don't have that special
overcome, that activation
energy, and you go back.
So let's just take a look
at some molecules checking
each other out and
figuring out if they have
what it takes, if they
have that critical energy.
Let's watch and
see what happens.
Here they come.
They're finding each other.
They're circling each other.
And oh my goodness.
They had the critical
energy necessary.
And they formed a
bigger yellow molecule.
There they go.
What a happy ending.
So only those molecules that
have that critical energy
can go on and form
their complex.
And so here is where
temperature comes into play.
Here is where temperature
becomes really important.
Because they need to have
a certain amount of energy.
And there's a relationship
between the kinetic energy
of molecules and
their temperature.
So let's take a look
at this plot over here.
So this is, on one axis,
fraction of molecules.
And on the other axis,
we have kinetic energy.
So if you're at low
temperature over here,
most of your molecules are going
to have a low kinetic energy.
But it will tail off.
And there will be some molecules
that will have a higher energy.
And if this line here
represents that minimum energy,
that critical energy or that
activation energy, in blue
here we have those low
temperature molecules.
Only a very small
fraction of those
will have the energy to react,
will be able to overcome
that minimum energy, that
critical energy needed.
Now if you're at
high temperature,
more molecules have a
higher kinetic energy.
And if you see over here shaded
in orange, way more molecules
have that critical
energy, have the energy
necessary to distort those bonds
and go on to make a molecule.
So here's where
temperature is important.
So kinetic energy, pass it on.
So let's draw some reaction
coordinates and think
about what's going on.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: For this
idea of collision,
could it also apply to
the association reactions?
Because that's
[INAUDIBLE] molecule.
Or are [? they still into ?]
each other? [INAUDIBLE]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yeah.
So if you're talking
about the forward reaction
and the backward
reaction of things,
whether it's two molecules
that are coming together
to form things or
molecules breaking apart,
there's a critical
energy both directions.
And we'll see that, actually.
It's a good question.
That kind of leads us in to our
reaction coordinate diagram.
So most of this
is in your notes.
There's a few
things that are not.
But let's look at a
reaction coordinate diagram.
And by that, I mean we have
Potential Energy, or PE,
on one side.
And on the other
axis, we have what's
called just the
reaction coordinate.
So if you're asked to draw a
reaction coordinate diagram
on a problem set or an exam,
asking for potential energy
versus reaction coordinate.
Now our reactants are going
to have a particular amount
of potential energy.
And in this case, it's up here.
And our products are going
to have some potential energy
down here.
And there will be a difference
in energy between these,
our delta E. But these
reactants aren't just
going to be able to go to
products without overcoming
some kind of critical energy.
So before they can go down
there, they need to go up here.
So we have the
activation energy,
f for forward direction.
Also, if you're down
in products and you
want to go back to reactants,
there's also a barrier
that you have to overcome.
And it's not just this.
It's all the way up here.
And so this would be
the activation energy
of the reverse reaction.
And this dashed line on the
top is our transition state
or our activated complex.
Both are two
expressions that are
used kind of interchangeably.
So this transition states,
some kind of weird mixture
where they've come
together, and they're sort
of breaking and distorting.
It's not our final products.
That's down here.
But you need to go up in energy,
overcome an activation energy
barrier.
So the transition here, you need
to go up, and then you go down.
So now let's think about
all of these energy terms.
And what's true is that the
change in energy-- this change
in energy between
reactants and products
is equal to our activation
energy for our forward reaction
minus the activation energy
of the reverse reaction.
And this delta E over
here can be measured
from a calorimetry experiment.
And you might
recall back when we
were talking about
thermodynamics that E
is kind of closely
related to delta H.
So we had this
equation at one point
that delta H is equal to
delta E plus the change in PV.
And we said that for gases,
there's about a 1% to 2%
difference between
delta H and delta E.
But for solids and liquids,
it's pretty much the same.
So you can think
about this delta E
like you were thinking about
delta H, for the most part.
So now for this, if we
have some of the numbers--
if you know activation energy
in the forward and the reverse,
you can calculate
delta E. If you
know delta E and one of
the activation energies,
you can calculate the other.
So I'll tell you for
this particular reaction
what these values are.
And I was going to
bring colored chalk,
and somehow that didn't happen.
So the activation energy in
this is not in your notes.
So I'll write it down.
Is 132 kilojoules per mole.
And I'll also put it
here, a little bigger,
132 kilojoules per mole.
And for the reverse reaction,
it's 358 kilojoules per mole
and minus 358
kilojoules per mole.
And so if we do
the math here, we
will calculate that delta E is
equal to minus 226 kilojoules
per mole.
So would you expect that to be
an endothermic or exothermic
reaction?
Exothermic.
Right.
And we can put that
value also in here,
minus 226 kilojoules per mole.
So what's really important
here, even though it's
exothermic reaction,
it's not going
to just go without having
those molecules have
some critical energy
necessary to overcome
this activation energy barrier.
You still need energy.
You need to go up here
before you can go down there.
So just sort of thinking
about this in layman's terms,
this idea of these
activation energy barriers,
for me whenever I sit down to
write a grant or write a paper,
I think, wow.
I sit down at my computer,
have my cup of coffee.
I know that we're about to
get scooped on this data.
So I really should write
this paper, a little stressed
about it.
Then I think, wow.
I could write a lot better
if my office was clean.
Now I hate cleaning my office.
But compared to writing a
paper, it's pretty good.
I don't mind doing it.
So then clean the office.
Then walk the dog.
Maybe do later some laundry.
Lots of things happen.
And then eventually, you
hear from the collaborators.
They're like, I
need this paper now.
And you're like, oh man.
And so that stress gets you over
that activation energy barrier,
just catapults you over.
Or you wait to a grant--
you start six months early.
And then the week
before it's due,
suddenly you have that nervous
energy that gets you over that.
So many of you have
probably experienced this.
And you know, if you need some
extra help with an activation
energy barrier to do the rest
of those extra problems for exam
four, you can come talk to me.
And I'll stress you out and get
you right over that activation
energy barrier.
But the thing to keep in mind
is that look at this slope
in this case down here.
So often it's just that little
something to get you over.
And then it's smooth sailing.
So you can work these
games with yourself.
You've just got to
get over it and know
that once you're
over that barrier,
it's all going to be good.
So you can get yourself over.
You should never forget about
activation energy barriers.
There's always a barrier.
Am I right?
There's always some
kind of barrier.
Anything you're going
to do that's worthwhile
has some barrier
associated with it.
So now let's think about the
results of these barriers,
again, coming back to
this idea of temperature.
So for an elementary
reaction-- again,
that's a reaction that
occurs exactly as written.
It's a step in an overall
reaction mechanism.
There's always a barrier,
always a barrier.
Barrier is always positive.
It's always there.
And so if you increase
the temperature,
you're always going to increase
the rate of that reaction.
It's always going to help
get over that barrier.
But increase the temperature,
increase the rate.
But for an overall
reaction, temperature
is a little more
complicated to predict.
So if you increase
the temperature,
it's not always as clear what's
going to happen to the rate.
Because you can have a lot
of different steps involved.
It can be exothermic
and endothermic.
A lot can be happening.
Changing the temperature,
you're changing k.
So to think about
an overall reaction,
we need to understand
reaction mechanisms.
And that's really
convenient because we just
talked about reaction
mechanisms on Monday.
So you all know how to write
out reaction mechanisms.
So let's just practice.
So for this example,
we have two molecules
of N O plus O2 going to 2NO2.
Step one, fast and reversible.
N O plus N O, going
to an intermediate.
Then the intermediate
is reacting
with oxygen going to two
molecules of our product.
So we can write the
rate of formation
of product based
on the slow step,
or if we didn't
know the slow set,
on the second step
or the last step.
So two molecules, again, two
molecules are being formed.
k2 times the concentration
of the intermediate times
the concentration of O2.
But we have an intermediate.
So we need to solve for
the intermediate in terms
of rate constants,
reactants, and products.
But now we're told we
have a fast step followed
by a slow step.
So we know how to do this.
And remember, when you have a
fast, reversible step followed
by a slow step, this first step
approximates an equilibrium
reaction.
There is not much of the
intermediate that's being
siphoned off in the slow step.
So pretty much, when you
form the intermediate,
it's going back and
forth just like you have
in an equilibrium situation.
And just to emphasize this,
I'll share a little picture
here of the beach in
the summer when you
don't need your winter coat.
And here we have my daughter
and her best friend.
And they are trying
to empty the ocean
with this princess bucket.
And one can ask the question, is
this going to affect the tides?
Is the ocean going
to be different?
But the rate at which
my daughter and Aiden
fill up their buckets
and bring them over here,
that's a really slow step
compared to everything
that's going on in the ocean.
So when you have a very
slow step like a kid
and a long distance
with a princess pail,
you don't really need
to worry about that.
And you can think about the fast
step as being an equilibrium.
This is not being siphoned
off enough to worry about it.
And so that makes it easier
to solve for your intermediate
because then you can just do it
by an equilibrium expression.
So in the clicker question,
tell me how I can do that.
AUDIENCE: I think you're good.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: OK.
10 more seconds.
So let's just take
a look at that.
So again, we're writing
our equilibrium expression
for the first step,
products over reactants.
And then we can rearrange it to
solve because the product here
is our intermediate.
So we can solve for the
intermediate in terms
of K1 and our reactant.
And then we can
substitute it in.
And that gives us this.
So we had the 2k2 here.
Now we have our K1
and our N O squared.
And here we have
our oxygen there.
So now we have a
rate law that doesn't
include any intermediates.
I'm just going to put
that back up here if you
didn't get it written down.
Now let's think of what
happens with temperature.
So this is an elementary
rate constant, little k2.
So you increase the rate when
you increase temperature.
And here is our
expression again that
tells us about that change.
So now for the
equilibrium constant,
the effect of
temperature depends on
whether the reaction is
exothermic or endothermic.
And does anyone remember
what the name of the equation
is that tells us about
temperature effect
with equilibrium constants?
Yes.
The van 't Hoff equation.
I told you that some
time in the future I'd
ask you for the name
of this equation.
And that time is now.
You don't really
need to know it.
But it's just fun.
There's not many names for
equations in general chemistry.
Look how similar
these equations are.
These are very
similar equations.
So we have the natural log
of rate constants here.
Here we have the natural log
of equilibrium constants.
Here we have our
activation energy.
Here we have delta H.
So if the reaction
is exothermic,
if we increase the
temperature, what
happens to our
equilibrium constant?
Does it increase or decrease?
You can just yell it out.
It decreases.
Now let's think about
what happens here.
So our kobs now has an
elementary rate constant term,
which is going to
increase with temperature.
And it has an equilibrium
constant term,
which is going to
decrease with temperature
for an exothermic reaction.
So we have these going
in opposite directions.
So overall, we want to
think about the magnitude
of our activation energy
term for our rate constants.
And we want to think about the
magnitude of our delta H term
in terms of the
equilibrium constants.
So for the particular reaction
in question, you can look up.
The activation energy
is a small number.
And delta H, again,
it's exothermic.
And it's a big number.
So then if you're
thinking about that,
if Ea is small and positive--
Ea is always positive.
There is always a
barrier, always positive.
Then the rate constant is only
going to increase a little bit.
But delta H is a
big negative number,
so the equilibrium constant
is going to decrease a lot.
So for this particular reaction,
increasing the temperature
actually decreases the kobs.
And so for any
reaction, it depends
on the magnitude of
Ea and the magnitude
and the sign of delta
H. So again, large Ea
means very sensitive
to temperature.
Large delta H means that
the equilibrium constant is
very sensitive to temperature.
For an elementary
rate constant, it's
always going to increase
with temperature.
Because Ea is always positive.
There is always a
barrier to overcome.
Temperature always
increases a rate constant.
But for an equilibrium
constant, it
can increase or decrease because
delta H isn't always positive.
Like the activation
energy barrier,
it can be positive or negative.
So the magnitude of delta
H, how big a number it is,
tells you about the
magnitude of the change,
how much the equilibrium
constant will change.
Will k1 and k2 be
almost like each other
or really, really different from
each other, those equilibrium
constants?
And the sign of delta H, whether
it's positive or negative,
tells you the direction
of the change.
Will it increase or decrease?
So I just want to
show where we're
going with this because
it's just super exciting.
Yes.
We're back to Le Chatelier.
This is what I was
so excited about.
Remember, Le Chatelier told
us, when we apply a stress
to the system, the system
responds in such a way
to minimize that stress.
So if we increase
the temperature,
according to Le
Chatelier, what direction
will the reaction
shift, in the exothermic
or the endothermic direction?
What is it?
The endothermic.
So you increase the temperature.
You add heat.
It shifts in a direction
to minimize that
or to use up that heat.
So we'll end with one
last clicker question.
And we'll finish this
concept on Monday.
But we want to think about how
Le Chatelier and what we've
known already applies here.
So why don't you tell me which
of these diagrams is exothermic
and which is endothermic?
Because we're going
to tie this all
back to temperature
and Le Chatelier.
AUDIENCE: We don't
have that question.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: We
don't have that question.
OK.
Then we will not
do that question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the question.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: OK.
So I'll just give you
the answer to that.
And then we'll see
who the winners are.
So that one is endothermic.
And this one is exothermic.
And we'll finish the
rest of this on Monday.
But for now, can you tell
us who the winner is?
No, it's not coming up.
AUDIENCE: It's Dan.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Top two.
AUDIENCE: Dan and Jay.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Dan and Jay
have beat out the other folks.
So we know who's
in the playoffs.
All right.
Friday exam.
See you Monday in class
to finish the handout.
All right.
Let's take 10 more seconds
on the clicker question.
So let's take a look at this.
56% do you have
the right answer.
So rate constants
always increase
with increase of temperature.
That's our little k's.
Because there is always
some activation energy
barrier to overcome.
There is always a
positive barrier.
Whereas, for equilibrium
constants, K,
you can have a reaction that's
exothermic or endothermic.
And so that will change.
It either increases or
decreases because delta H
can be positive or negative.
But activation energy
barriers are always positive.
There's always a barrier.
Always a barrier to doing
anything that's important.
I've got to calm down.
Le Chatelier tells me that
when a stress is applied
to the system, I should
respond in such a way
to minimize the stress.
It's a very calming
rule in chemistry.
Reactions don't like stress.
And they'll respond in
a way to minimize it.
So we've been talking
about Le Chatelier
for a lot of the semester.
And we've talked about
the effect of temperature
on reactions previously.
So if you add heat
to a reaction,
it will want to respond in
such a way to minimize the heat
or absorb the heat.
So it shifts in the
endothermic direction.
So we've already
talked about this.
And nothing is new here today.
But today, I'm going to
give you a different way
to rationalize why that happens.
So we're not changing
what happens.
We're just going to
come up with a new way
to rationalize the why.
So we ended last time
with these two diagrams.
And we identified one
as endothermic and one
as exothermic.
So these, again, are our
reaction coordinate diagrams.
We have PE on one side.
What does PE stand for again?
Potential energy.
It stands for other things too,
but in a reaction coordinate
diagram, that's what it is.
And then the reaction
coordinate going this way.
So we go from reactants to
products along the reaction
coordinate.
So here in this
endothermic reaction,
we have our reactants down
here, our products up here,
and a very large
activation energy barrier
for the forward direction, a
much smaller activation energy
barrier for the
reverse direction.
With the exothermic
reaction here, we
have a smaller
activation energy barrier
for the forward direction
and a bigger one
for the reverse direction.
So let's look at the
one equation that
will be on the exam that will
not be on your equation sheet.
I think this is--
for this unit, this
is the one that will be
not on your equation sheet.
This change in energy is
equal to the activation
energy for the
forward direction the
of reaction minus
the activation energy
for the reverse reaction.
And again, this is
our delta E here.
And this is our delta E here.
Delta E is like delta H. If
you're talking about a gas,
it's 1% to 2% different.
If you're talking about
a solid or a liquid,
it's negligibly different.
So if we look at this
endothermic reaction here,
we have a big forward
activation energy
barrier minus a small reverse
activation energy barrier.
So that's going to give us a
positive value for delta E.
And it'll be an
endothermic reaction.
And if we look at this
equation again and fill it
in for the exothermic
reaction, we
have a small barrier in
the forward direction,
a big barrier in the
reverse direction,
and a negative value
for delta E and delta H.
It's an exothermic reaction.
Now let's think about
what happens when
we increase the temperature.
So if we increase
temperature, it's
a lot easier to overcome this
forward activation energy
barrier, the big one.
And that's going to
shift it to products.
And this is because the small
activation energy barrier,
it's not that hard
to get over something
that's a small activation
energy barrier.
It's not hard.
But if it's a
really big barrier,
it's hard to get
over that barrier.
You need a lot of
kinetic energy.
Increasing the temperature
will give that kinetic energy
to overcome that barrier.
Remember that when
molecules come together,
bonds are distorted and formed.
The potential energy
goes up first.
And only those molecules
with that critical energy
that can overcome that
activation energy barrier
can go on to products.
Increase the temperature,
that allows you
to overcome the big barrier.
Now if we look in this side,
this is a small barrier.
They weren't really
having-- molecules
were probably not having
a huge amount of trouble
with that barrier.
The barrier that was hard was
for the reverse direction.
So now you increase
the temperature
of an exothermic reaction.
It's easier to overcome this big
barrier, the reverse barrier.
And you have a shift
toward reactants.
So this is what we
had seen before.
You increase the temperature
of an endothermic reaction.
You go to products.
You increase the temperature
of an exothermic reaction.
It shifts to reactants.
So these are the same
things we saw before.
But now there's a new
rationalization behind it.
Now we can think about this
in terms of activation energy
barriers.
So the important
points to remember,
big activation energy
barrier, rate constant
very sensitive to temperature.
If you have a big barrier,
increasing the temperature
makes a big difference.
If you have a small
barrier, doesn't really
matter that much.
Most of your molecules can
get over that small barrier.
So big barrier, increasing
the temperature,
more molecules can go.
And so you're going to
shift in the direction
of the big barrier.